blah blah blah we're live we're not live
we're live from Austin Texas
so Trevor Wallace hosted the bird
Crusher roast sure did could have had
anyone chose Trevor thank you why'd you
say yes by the way were you scared was
that like a no-brainer or were you kind
of like it was a no-brainer I was like
yeah it sounds fun as time kept
progressing I was like oh this is like
legit legit like like 19 cameras call
times Cruiser 5 a.m eating Red Vine
licorice it's a whole and so I was like
oh I better get my shit straight I think
one of the mistakes although maybe it's
not a mistake but I really wanted
letting Bert drink okay that bird and
Donnell was a shit face oh I love them
more than anything what are you guys
doing yeah but it was the most on brand
like it would have been weird if he was
up there at the very end being like hey
guys I am Bert uh you know thanks for
coming out the fact that he was are We
Done Yet in the middle of it
like laugh and be like where's my drink
yeah yeah it was just like so endearing
because it's like I wanted to be a
little bit like feel like control chaos
because it's like the roads that weren't
Comedy Central it always felt so like
sterile and formal and like comedians
normally dress like you know in hoodies
and you know Crocs are like wearing like
suits cool shit and look like they're in
a W hotel lobby and everyone's so
nervous yeah I just wanted to feel like
stupid it's like that's right bro we
made like clowns and idiots and everyone
said no the production value and the
whole set design everybody that worked
on it was great it looked phenomenal
we're gonna play some of Trevor's jokes
that we didn't end up putting in the
first cut but we're gonna do a big like
super cut drop some extra uncut jokes
later
um uncut jokes because I prefer uncut
let's be honest feels better
um smells worse and let's go someone
Trevor's cut jokes but it's an honor to
have you here Live In the Flesh and not
at one of your shows in a baseball field
or cruise ship or water park or wherever
your family isn't yes
I thought that one should have made it
great but then Tom kind of did that joke
and yeah but who's Tom's girl
Diners Drive-Ins and deadbeat dads
those are bangers look call the editing
team get it in
but honestly I'm just excited to be here
when Whitney asked me to host I was like
me
to kid in his 20s who got big on the
internet like these roasts are usually
filled with Legends like Greg Giraldo
Norm Macdonald Betty White and then I
saw the lineup and I was like I'll be
all right
both these are funny
like a drunk tank fucked
and Bert halves fucked the waffle house
before
I mean come on guys we got what six guys
two girls with a ratio like that it's no
wonder Tony Hinchcliffe said yes to this
all right
the only thing this Deus is missing is a
Brazzers logo you know
I can see it now
you know Comet gets smashed by six guys
fun funny thinking of not coming uh
Bert's best friend Tom Segura
this is all good it's all brilliant
I got my number five minutes to be here
and he was lying but he said
I guess the best way to get famous is
just to have famous friends so Whitney
what a friend
somebody you don't have to pay this part
didn't hit but the horses dogs don't
count did it's great to be doing this
it's just more about like whatever you
want being on for a long time and you
had such huge cute kids yeah we're good
we're doing comedy on only fans
do you have any comedy on only fans like
having a vegan menu a Cracker Barrel
ain't nobody gonna see that shit
that shit big puck that's a good joke
put it in wait can you pause okay so I
knew this would happen it's Banger after
Banger the whole it was three hours of
bangers you know what I mean but it's
like I was like do we do an hour and a
half and then of it's like they're like
well most of our you know is naked women
we don't know anything you know what yes
and no but like they're they're doing a
lot of like TV stuff
coming up they're like 15 minutes is
usually what we do so I'm like let's
just do 50 minutes because these are
gonna be roasts they're both gonna be 50
minutes and then let's see if we lose
any retention whatever and then
regardless I'm gonna do other remixes
dropping later of the other yeah as long
as I can get mine clip it up no I'll
give you the whole thing obviously but I
then want to drop all of this in you
know a lot of different ways because
it's like we overshot stuff so everyone
had content for their Instagrams that or
Tick Tock whatever that aren't the same
as what's already on the show you know
what I mean so you're gonna get
exclusive you're gonna get uh traffic on
exclusive Clips on your Instagram that
aren't in here so they're not like I'm
just saying the same thing that already
aired right you know so I want to be
able to provide like yeah
saw on uh socials I was told this is
actually on only fans TV and I'm not
sure if this is Union but I do know for
a fact Bert's tits are sad
good La joke it was a little more like
inside baseball
well let's be honest dude if we're on
only fans like the only reason I go on
there is I can see a girl shot put a
GoPro for birth canals all right
and at that rate she'd probably be
passed to The Comedy Store before I am I
mean what the fuck am I not pass here
for four years we're parked Bobby Lee's
coming fasted Audi but no
bullshit
but you know what I have done
ladies and Gentlemen please use my promo
code
dude brand is the way of the future
that's how I make my money so I thought
I'd bring a couple brand news here
tonight to help the Davis right start it
off you know like Jim you're like this
stuff wouldn't fit in the cut you showed
me their photos
10 versions of it
how does that work for you you know
but if you get a request from Donnell on
there uh for abortion money he's really
just trying to pay off another DUI
too
I got two different time to charm
and we are back from a quick
intermission from betterhelp.com thank
you so much
thank you so much you can see I'm at
Saddle Ranch talking to 19 year olds
after this
[Laughter]
is me the this one that's so funny you
should do that I'm gonna get my ass beat
tonight please help me yeah that's
hilarious a few months ago texted me out
of the blue and he asked me to do his
podcast and I was so excited to talk to
him and then I did his podcast and I
still haven't talked to him all right
I sat in silence for two hours
this is cool this is nodding my head oh
yeah totally whoa alcohol sick man get
help okay
I felt like I was being trapped in a
Spotify attic couldn't skip dude
finally figured out how Tom seguro was
able to do so many podcasts without
getting burnt out uh because he doesn't
talk on one of them I wonder which one
you guys know what podcast I'm talking
about right uh your mom's house that
Christina P1 shut the fuck up
oh
even before you text me Bert I was
surprised that you knew who I was right
that's pretty sick and then I remembered
that I'm sponsored by Natty Lyon
wetzel's pretzels and I was like oh yeah
he knows exactly exact the fuck I am
nobody knows more about booze and beer
than Bert all right when Birds hops out
he doesn't yell Uncle he goes auntie
and then comes so great the way you
deliver that is brilliant it's because
he needs a dipping sauce
[Music]
but you can check out that new recipe on
his new Show filming another one out of
his house because that's what they need
his new show Comedians and carbs getting
cane cool
but the man's a fucking Legend dude
you've been through a lot of ups and
downs not with your career just deep
throat and Push Pops
Leanne hold my back hair
not too hard I came again
that wasn't so hard was it what's worse
for your dignity posting a crowdware
clip on your Instagram or promoting two
for one tickets at the Tulsa Looney band
no seriously big J tell me what's worse
than that as uh
I'm fucking you dude I'm Kenny BJ sells
tickets he sells tickets he actually
just headlined the Groupon of the
Juggalos but Whitney I do hope use
protection uh the last thing you want is
an answer
I'm kidding I'm very I know Brendan very
well okay he always wears protection
he's actually not allowed to leave the
house without a helmet so he's always
Brennan I love you
he's bringing it back dude social media
is a way of the future I don't even want
to do these late night sets if I wanted
to watch a bunch of Boomers fall asleep
during my set I just host the fucking
roast of Burt Chrysler yeah all this
feels too believe me late night is dead
you know it needs to be like it didn't
have that
it's so great it's just like yeah I
think being cut up in different
iterations and then doing a super cut of
the ones you don't want to use yeah man
it airs every Tuesday at 2 p.m yeah like
this part just like this is one station
but it's great he'll throw it up for
free if you buy a puff bar
or if you go to Yahoo finance you scroll
all the way to the bottom to the comedy
section yeah
it's right there just use my promo code
I should have been a dentist cool
Lord I love your crying it's like
nothing else Birds crying sounds like
somebody's letting helium out of a
balloon just like
Jay will be selling whippets in the
parking lot
[Applause]
[Laughter]
incredible life what other fat drunk has
had two movies made about them
the new movie coming out of course is
based on the machine story right it's
been the sheen story
[Applause]
because Bert relies on the machine for
his career more than Stephen Hawking all
right let's
go when I was 22 I got involved with the
Russian model
[Applause]
bring me my fun dip Leanne
but let's just hope that this film is as
good as your first film super-sized
I'm not even kidding dude Super Size Me
is a way more accurate burnt Chrysler
biopic than Van Wilder right they had
Ryan Reynolds play you in college he
played Deadpool
and you look like you were found dead in
a pool
your first roaster is Jim Norton he
actually used to be on the radio and
Legend has it still is uh
somebody started GoFundMe Jim might seem
old and out of touch but his face has
been on Twitch for over 30 years
but he is surprisingly woke his pronouns
are actually albino you guys feeling
good your next comic is Tony Hinchcliffe
but the guy's a real comedy veteran uh
mainly because he hates Asians
these are all just like cut up we could
stop now because he's all the intros I
thought the experience was so cool and I
was so in my head and I just watched my
cut of the set and I was like oh it's
great great I was in my head because I
was like I wish it was like a TV taping
or not TV tipping a special tape when I
was like there was like a couple
recordings of it but that wouldn't be
authentic because if Bert had to hear
the same jokes again I'd be like huh so
yeah we did live in front of the
audience but I did like something that I
always like to do is especially with the
host like because you're you know doing
the most heavy lifting yeah um is to
pre-shoot it so remember we pre-shot it
of course I pre-shot mine because I knew
that uh you know what I was gonna be
performing live I was gonna have to be
yelling and basically wrangling the
crowd remember I had to kick someone out
during my set yeah I mean it's sanity
but there's so much that like I was
everyone I've talked to about this I'm
like Whitney is just like her is just
unmatched of just like 30 000 things
going on at once producing being funny
this that like shut the fuck up don't
crack that can get that person out of
here put your phone down Jim Norton
everybody and then you're doing yourself
it just it's mind just watching it
happen I go this is a lady who knows the
fuck she's doing we know it's wild after
that we did two rows we did the one of
Burke Chrysler and the one of oh Whitney
Cummings because I mean I remember when
I was choosing who to roast which I'm
really curious who you think should be
next because it's such a tricky thing
casting who's gonna be roasted Jake Paul
you know what I talked to Logan Paul
about it but he's got some kind of deal
with some other thing like he started
his own only fans or something really
told only fan because he has one there
it is put it in put it in the Rose
telegraphers we're putting it in the
ropes I love Logan I love those guys
Jake's honestly a nice guy you want to
hate him when you meet him and he's just
like he's got that cool like rapper Vibe
yeah these motherfuckers it's just like
there's something about Shameless
ambition like I'm I'm very ambitious I
don't you know it's like whatever what's
up ambition save me but like I don't I
don't know what else we're doing if
you're not gonna go for number one like
what are we doing yeah I mean honestly
to go from Disney Channel to fighting is
pretty big usually go from Disney
Channel to fighting your inner demons so
good for him because think about like so
traditionally the show from Disney to
fighting off the police that are taking
you through 5150 like to go from Disney
to making millions boxing that's like
probably one of the most successful
person people from Disney in quite some
time I feel like if you you know we're a
Disney star you we probably got a lot of
practice punching men to try to get them
away from you when they're molesting you
so well there's that angle yeah who is
Dan Schneider is he Nickelodeon Harley
Miranda Cosgrove oh heard of her
have I she this is gonna sound dumb but
she looks exactly how you think she
would like does that sound dumb but like
you're like okay I've seen you on TV
yeah and then I see you in life and
you're like that's the same you know
what that's a really good observation
because like you'll see people on TV and
then you see them in person right oh
lighting is Magic uh well you're right
but like you'll see somebody's like oh
that's the guy from Lost and you're like
the man asking for money up for an
arowan great place to ask for money
honestly for me it's like you see me on
TV and you're like oh she has such great
skin then you see me in person you're
like is that Steve Buscemi it's but
you're exactly right I mean she is a
Westworld robot yeah just just but it
looks like
like just offset and then boom right
there
I love that this is how a man uh gives a
woman the ultimate We're Not Gonna
compliment she is as pretty in person as
she is on TV that is the ultimate
compliment yes
I didn't see I didn't know if it'd be
weird to be like you look like you look
on TV and she's like yeah yeah like okay
I I'm so bad with compliments I don't
know how to do you think this has to do
with like you know our like these days
uh these days that you you don't talk my
generation as I was saying I was about
to say you just steal the Facebook
people right now like you'll see a girl
on you know Instagram or whatever yeah
then you see you're in person and she's
like wait a second I thought your eyes
were twice as bad like you see bitches
with filters all the time so by the time
you see them in person is that a thing I
just realized that like getting
catfished because you're like oh shit
yeah it's like catfished adjacent it's
still the same person it's not like some
man from Dubai who you're texting with
it's still the same person just you know
it's like it maybe it was a little a
little little tweetly yeah but it's like
do you like I
because I feel like also a lot of
younger girls now are getting like work
done and like lip fillers and stuff like
that which I'm not gonna criticize I
like that look yeah I mean look you're
just want your dick sucked by a catfish
I get it really by anything honestly
throw a trout on that bitch
and so I'm just curious like I just feel
like what if you marry a girl who like
should you like I would just need to see
the baby pictures oh I need to know what
our kids gonna look like well the second
the kid comes out he's going to Doctor
Miami
and he he's getting botched up it's not
oh his teeth haven't grown in yet good
give him veneers it's cheaper suck him
right in I one time went to a
dermatologist in La when I first moved
here and um I went to get I don't know I
was getting a laser hair removal
um and I'm still bald wish I could have
it back pubes are really by the way
they're back but who's saying this who's
telling you this 29 year old got him
dating
I'm just saying they're I think there's
something maybe a dude told you this
yeah cause he's just too lazy to to
shave he's like ah baby come on they're
back huh you're like fuck oh guys shave
now it's such a it's just sort of
manscape trim it up yeah promo code
Whitney here's the thing stiff socks
for winning
um if you're going to shave though you
guys don't understand you can you got to
do it like all the time because if
they're stubble that's gonna rub five
o'clock shadow though not dude that
means 9 A.M gyno appointment you know
what I mean so it's like if you're
rubbing against it why is gynecologist
open so early
uh you think it would be like from like
9 P.M to like midnight dim the lights
like in 20 hours yeah you get up you're
in the same traffic as somebody going to
Merrill Lynch in the morning just so you
can do this
I think that's also what they do in
Maryland let's be honest true yeah but I
feel like uh uh because then I remember
like when like sometimes I would like
have sex with a guy or something who um
sometimes should I say hook up with what
are we supposed to say what is yeah hook
up yeah does hookup mean sex yeah okay
but my parents don't know that they're
always like your cousin's in town you
guys should hook up and I'm like which
cousin I thought hook up was what you
had to do to have an abortion in Texas
Whitney what
do you want okay so there's other Shades
too I don't know but then it then I
would always think I had herpes because
it would rub and then I'd have like
these red bumps and I'm like no I got
herpes and I'm gonna call the guy and be
like yeah oh you would call you wouldn't
even give it 12 hours to well I couldn't
afford to go to a gynecologist at the
time I would like go to you know I don't
know drive through Urgent Care or
something somewhere in East Hollywood
is anything good happen in East
Hollywood if we go to a psychic and be
like can you take a look at this yeah
and so she's reading it like Braille but
like what you need to fuck cleaner dudes
oh gosh guys guys guys guys guys you
better help me out on this one this
podcast is brought to you by betterhelp
getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because
we're always growing and changing
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding so that
you're not a punk sometimes we don't
know what we want or why we react the
way we do until we talk through things
better help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can take you on that
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are so therapy you know has changed
my life especially doing it online
because back in my day we used to wear
newspapers on our feed and walk down to
the therapy kiosk in the Town Square in
my day we'd have to talk to a priest
through a screen wall
um to me one of the biggest stresses
about going to therapy was like I'm too
busy it's going to stress me out to go
to therapy and the whole point of going
to therapy is to de-stress so doing it
remotely has been a total Game Changer
also I think that my therapist has
really been able to glean a lot about me
that I can't see for myself by looking
at the background of our our Zoom
sessions
they're like ah I'm not really listening
to what you're saying I'm more concerned
with the 72 figurines you have behind
you from the movie Labyrinth let's talk
about that Whitney and I'm like what
it's not a hoarding it's called
collecting if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire and get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge
um discover your potential with better
help visit betterhelp.com Whitney today
to get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com witness on my
roast uh myros airs uh May 14th on only
fans TV and it's free they're just still
Panic
um everyone's like you have to have an
account like no it's don't you how come
you went with birds before yours for a
couple reasons number one I think
um most people hate female comedians uh
most people I'm kidding um no I think
that like Birds is actually much like
warmer like mine is Savage really mine
is Savage I was talking hosts mine yeah
stocking host mine I mean her jokes are
so like I think for me for whatever
because I have done Rose before
historically I did Donald Trump's I did
hasselhoffs I did Joan Rivers and I'm
kind of like known for that I feel like
Bert's I don't know was just gonna I
think that dude Perfect's a good one
another thing about it yeah so so
popular and so lovable and I really
wanted to show that yeah you know I
really did this in reaction to Chris
Rock being punched in the face by Will
Smith and no one even standing up to
help you punks and seeing like you know
uh like Jada like roll her eyes at the
joke and US knowing like we know that
Will Smith like Chris Rock had so many
brutal jokes that he was like no no
let's take it easy on them you know like
a GI Jane joke that was him like being
you know throwing a softball and then
for that to happen was just sort of like
I really wanted to show because then
everyone's like comedians are punching
down and comedians are bullies like get
the fuck out of here like and so showing
these rows uh how we can sort of like do
it with love and what started happening
is like I just don't think Comedians and
non-comedians should really mix when it
comes to roasting and joking oh right so
it's like it's like like for me roasts
are like verbal MMA you know yeah and in
MMA or boxing or whatever like you have
weight class you've been hanging out
with Rogan too much you've been hanging
out the Rogan way too much you know
life's like MMA you either Punch or you
get punched we did it you did Mothership
how was it we get jabbed or good job
your ears will swell up at the Johnson
Johnson job have not been the same sense
and uh no it's like it's like that's
what it is it's like verbal MMA we're
going backwards but if like you mix a
heavy weight with a featherweight it
feels mean whether you're punching or
doing this so for me yeah it's like
heavy weights only all the Comedy
Central ones there was always somebody
on I forget who there's there's one
Courtney some I forget to ask him she
gets like every butt end of the joke
into all the comments
no I don't I don't forget who was but a
lot of the rose resurfaces on Tick Tock
lately because like Pete's doing them
this Courtney Cox maybe I think she did
one uh yeah I don't know but but like
all the comments are eventually they're
like this is like fucked like she is
getting destroyed and she's just sitting
there like um okay
wow no it's here's the thing like I mean
I wrote on the roasts forever
um I did Flavor flaves I did the reason
I got hired is because
um these five dudes that always did The
Comedy Central roast I was like 22 or
something and I just like I knew because
what I love about Rose jokes is they're
like math they're just like a clean yeah
airtight like you know where to start
and finish and then you're just figuring
out the rest because like comedy like
when you're doing like stand up it's
like you get to you know tell these
stories but roasts are just like math
jokes and I love doing jokes that other
people it's like a challenge because
it'll be like oh Whitney is really
sensitive about blank or Whitney has a
story about this and then you go how do
I get from A to Z and in the middle
you're like how do I there's something
funny here how do I just make it smart
because if you just said when he has
blah blah blah they're like boring but
if you're like that's so much like this
that's why I do it yeah it's so it's fun
to like set it up and then like slam
dunk yourself exactly but it's also it's
like it's like surgical you know and
there's also something funny about you
know it's so mathematical and I really
love writing jokes and having jokes
available that other people can tell at
work the next day you know what I mean
things that are repeatable yeah it's not
necessarily always dependent on delivery
you know it's just like a great job like
you know Greg Geraldo one of my favorite
jokes of his it was on um uh the Flavor
Flav roast he said iced tea you're so
old you used your first residual check
to buy your freedom
how to really deliver it which is like
such a great yeah you know and there's
something just like I love that like
surprising people that way and uh and
it's not something I really do in my
stand-up anymore because it's like now
we're sort of doing this thing where
we're authentic and tell the truth and
um I think that a lot of people like
don't want to see like jokes and stand
up anymore like I feel that you know
what I mean they want to like have punch
lines but they don't want to die but
they also want to feel like you're like
involving it's like you're like in this
mix and you want to be talked too yeah
you know it's like people want to be
talked too right now instead of just
like if I'm just performative then
there's the slowly there's a little bit
of a disconnect but you're just telling
like a good story I mean that's why
Bert's so great he's just he's just like
he's just like telling me about his
weekend he's telling about his life but
he he can make an arena or a softball
field or wetzel's pretzels where the
fuck he's performing he can make it feel
like at home wetzel's pretzels Arena
there's a Smoothie King Arena I'm like
how the fuck does Smoothie King have
this much money drug front drug front
probably where it even is Smoothie King
what is it Jamba Juice no we used to do
Smoothie King when I went to school in
Philadelphia that shit was everywhere
really King is it East Coast thing I
think so okay
we had Jamba Juice blenders in the grass
this was in Oxnard uh uh whoa but
careful to get clipped here no uh no I
can't really camera camera California
which is 10 minutes from Oxnard okay
nice something else that I think is so
funny like when we went to dinner that
time and we were like just what is
having a great roast joke sorry you guys
I have um
um what uh what was that what Michael
Douglas had which throat cancer from
eating chlamydia pussy
um do you remember that no okay Michael
Douglas what is it don't you get like
strep throat if you eat bad bad bad
pussy isn't that a thing I don't think
so this is like in the same bro logic of
what Louis C.K did that joke about how
um one of his friends was like I'm
hooking up with this girl tonight and he
was drinking milk and he's like I'm
drinking milk so I can come a lot
[Music]
yeah your body's like white like it's
just yeah of course of course that's why
I drink Mountain Dew okay Michael
Douglas had stage four squamous cell car
kind of damn it carcinoma oral cancer
you have that no Michael Douglas did I
was joking this is just like uh did HPV
gave Michael Douglas throat cancer it
was caused by HPV contracted through
oral sex oh this dude ain't so much
boxes you have to watch that stuff dude
because it's like HPV is not a game I
got vaccinated by from uh uh there's an
HPV vaccine and when I was in my 20s uh
I like went to the gynecologist for like
the first time when I was like 24 and
she was like you should probably get the
HPV vaccine and I was like like yes but
I just was like STDs are just like my
nightmare like I'm just like yes of
course because I just knew I the kind of
guys I roll with the just like
love strippers and so I was like I gotta
get this HPV vaccine it was like 400.
three of them you had to do them before
you were 27 that feels like so arbitrary
now when you think about it and I would
sell clothes at Buffalo Exchange uh the
guys that I was dating I would sell
their clothes at Buffalo Exchange and
then I would do um you would sell their
clothes so wait can I have a hoodie to
wear at home and then he's like yeah for
sure and then you just straight to
Buffalo Exchange so they grab their Air
Force Ones they're just like and then I
would do uh focus groups and then I
would do clinical trials yeah you know
for a lot of drugs that never passed the
FDA so when people think I'm a little
off and tweaked like it could be that
when I think about it you know I mean
like I did all these like you know when
you you would see in like the back of La
weekly like have depression like come
try this pill a clinical trial and I
would go and they'd be like how much
would they pay you uh fifty dollars a
day cash so be mean a bunch of fucking
meth ads yeah you know yeah I know but
as you know you're on your tweaker shit
when you start the emphasis is that it's
cash
yeah yeah I'm like I suck a dick cash
are you literally show up in these
studies like UCLA and it would just be
like so are you depressed and you're
like like I've never felt like I was
depressed but it's sort of like well I
am at a study for 50 bucks so yeah this
you're like depressed uh let's see
what's the word here desperate I was
yeah I wasn't depressed till I walked in
here and realized I was about to take an
unapproved pill for depression and then
um and it's actually fascinating because
I was trying to like write a joke about
this but uh I just haven't like gotten
to it yet it's like you know like side
effects on stuff on like pills it's like
dizziness drowsiness
what is it I usually think it's the
opposite this is like low sex drive it's
like you look at these antidepressants
it's like in order to cure your
depression you have to have like dry
mouth dizziness low sex drive it's like
yeah it feels like
I just I did just go off Prozac recently
so yeah we'll see I just like I don't
know I feel like um well I did this is
so stupid my uh uh I was prescribed five
grams of extended release Adderall and
10 milligrams of Prozac and I was on
them for in the five milligrams of uh
Adderall was to sleep to sleep because
if you have OCD I'm about to ask if I
could take that shit it's like an edit
on this flight tomorrow it actually
calms you know you can take some but
that I was taking it for like a couple
weeks and I told the doctor I was like
yeah I think it's like really working
and he was I was like you know this is
like perfect like yeah um and uh the
Prozac I think is helping and he was
like I mean I do technically have to
tell you that the Adderall was a placebo
dose
um it the five milligram was actually uh
made of placebo dose because they knew
it would be prescribed to kids
wow and I was like what the fuck is
going on with you people now you're back
at the UCLA clinical day so like we're
just trying but here's six bucks
I can stop experimenting on me but like
placebo effect isn't a fact so like I
fuck with it and so um uh okay so I'm
doing these focus groups dude and like
you go in like I would do it for like
Neutrogena and for L'Oreal they would
send you a product you like try it and
you would go in it'd be like a group of
like 10 people and you would like talk
about it and like if you talk the more
you talked about it the more they would
ask you you would get an email list and
they'd ask you to do another study you
know so I was like the overachieving
like Tracy flick of the studies where I
would just be like you know and I
actually think I they made a lot of
changes based on my feedback because
there was like a like a Neutrogena like
brush like a tool and I like used it I
was like you know here's the problem is
I think it's gonna need to be cleaner
and this is what should be changed about
it and like all the meth heads that
we're just trying to get 50 bucks were
like
but it was like it was just like I would
do the most it would be like oh and then
this and this and what's your feedback
and I'm like what else I think and
they'd be like
and then they kept calling me back to do
more and more focus groups and the more
and more focus groups you do the more
you start running into the same people
so it would be like the same eight of us
at many focus groups right it'd be like
Advil men and Trail Neutrogena L'Oreal
like NyQuil and then you start realizing
that like the same people kind of like
they'll be like how are you feeling now
and somebody like I just I'm kind of
dizzy whatever and they'd go great and
they go to someone else and be like how
are you feeling like I'm kind of tired
like right and then uh someone else will
be like um how are you feeling they're
like I don't know I'm just kind of like
like my back hurts or whatever and then
you get to know these people and I was
like see them out and I'll be like
they'd be like I'm drowsy and I'd be
like that's not dude Jocelyn's like
always kind of drowsy dude that's just
his personality like that's not you
can't this is can't go you gotta get a
better sample like dude I'm telling you
like I've seen this guy not on the like
oh he's always kind of like tired like
and then you
look effects and it's like
it's like drowsiness oh yeah it's like a
fucking like it's the Seven Dwarves
they're just playing it safe they're
just like it's one of these but they're
just saying what they need to say to get
the fifty dollars and get to the next
thing so all these side effects like I
don't know if I buy any of that shit
because the people that are in studies
are kind of Performing yeah while the
side effects also are like death and I'm
like I'm gonna fucking OD on Advil if I
die on Advil good I went to fucking rest
in peace literally I am at peace I feel
good dude no headaches no anxious
okay there ZocDoc it's time to talk
about health you guys it's a whole thing
ZocDoc is here to help you it's the only
free app that lets you find and book
doctors who are patient reviewed take
your insurance are available when you
need them and treat almost every
condition Under the Sun probably
including sun damage when you're not
feeling your best and just trying to
hold it together
finding great care should not take up
all your energy that's isn't ain't that
the truth that's where ZocDoc comes in
using their free app that millions of
users rely on you can find the right
doctor that meets your needs and fits
your schedule book an appointment with a
few Taps on their app and start feeling
better and faster with ZocDoc these are
legitimate doctors they are patient
reviewed I had to actually use ZocDoc
recently
um because I did have a run-in with a
raccoon and in Los Angeles fentanyl has
made it apparently into the water supply
so there's there's fentanyl raccoons
fentanyl coyotes you name it they've got
fentanyl in them and so I had to go to
zogdog to find the closest hospital that
had a rabies vaccine and they told me
the Tarzana hospital had it I got there
no problem handled it I was like
this is very you know I mean I'm gonna
die soon but I'm glad I was able to use
this app that um kind of Saved My Life
let's be honest go to zocdoc.com Whitney
and download the ZocDoc app for free
find them and book a top-rated doctor
today menu are available within 24 hours
that's zoc doc
zocdoc.com Whitney zocdoc.com Whitney
and stay away from uh raccoons obviously
a reference whore like picking the right
reference you know when like you're
writing a joke specifics you know when
you're like writing a joke and you start
going like and then I saw him six times
and then you're like four times the
funnier like you know when you're just
like look at the randomness yeah but
you're just picking a number that's
funnier and you don't really know why
but there's like a like kind of it's
like there is an art to it but it's like
or like when Comics are on the same page
and you're like oh and then then the
bonds and yeah and then Ralphs and
you're like
John that's where I like I had something
about like Spike TV and people like oh
hilarious
yeah Spike TV days we need to get back
to that back when men were men I have a
whole bit about how I used to Huff ax
body spray and like that like just
everyone there's like fucking seventh
grade memories just exploding do you did
you guys have um I mean I'm 10 years
older than you right uh hyper color
shirts
I don't think so dude I have some here
they were assured that we used to wear
it was a tie-dye shirt it said hyper
color on it and when you sweat it would
change colors oh what the fuck I
definitely have breast cancer but it was
like it like slap bracelets that was too
early bracelets I know yeah silly bands
dude beanie babies
like people are all like Bitcoin this
that like that shit dude I remember my
aunts would collect beanie babies and
they were in a glass case and we weren't
allowed to touch them they would also go
on the back of the the what's it when
the back seat of the car where the back
windshield they'd be like so that the
dog oh I know whoever was behind you
baby people have like stick figures of
their family this is just like a little
Beanie Baby Bear but what's funny is
like now it's like we're coming full
circle now that Pokemon cards are like
valuable and they've been had but like
there's gonna be guys out there who are
like dude I'm making 12K a week flipping
beanie babies like garyvee is going to
be going to garage sales back where's
your beanie babies 30 cents I'll give
you 14 cents boom flips it now he's a
trillionaire what is garyvee what do you
mean you don't know who he is I mean I
do it's just like an entrepreneur who
just braces a bunch of shit
uh who's he's our what he's the new
blank I like doing a they're the new
blank they're the new Tony Robbins
they're the new he's embarrassed he's
his own personality he's just what does
he write when he goes to the doctor
occupation
he's the type of guy who would look at
that and go
um
life garyvee has 160 million dollars
dude he's out here he's he's just he
just fires up Bros he drinks like bang
energy before work he just like fire
stuff and then really quick how many
people have died three children killed
by playing Pokemon go when teenagers
just like jump off cliffs to try to get
a Pokemon
it's called Darwinism folks you know I
didn't know people still played Pokemon
go um well
um
am I let's get to it who are you dating
I'm not dating anyone how is it going
out there I need to know I have
questions it's good but it is
um you know because when I was in a
relationship for so long that like you
forget about like kind of like a bunch
of the the dates and stuff and then it's
like it's fun and you're going out and
you're having a couple drinks all of a
sudden it's like five in the morning and
you're like what am I doing with my life
is that Fentanyl
the nights are fun and they're great but
you meet a lady you have a time but like
you need like a date what's a date now
what do you do you meet on what I don't
use apps plenty of catfish
plenty of trout that's what I use
you don't use the apps
been on the right waiting this for like
10 months no
no and then do the approval do not like
your hairline It's that or my conspiracy
whoa I know that's a big word it
actually is a conspiracy no here's the
thing because it links to your Instagram
I think that there's watch my videos but
not funny get them off or they think
I'll clean up too much that's what it is
no I literally like it's to the point
where I'm like guys past me like I have
friends like oh yeah I know the CEO and
I'm like cool DM him now I mean
literally like Paulie Shores on there I
mean you we can get you on there no but
like Paulie legit famous but like
there's like people that I know that are
like oh I was a PA on Euphoria four
years ago and I'm on there and I'm like
why are you also Euphoria I ca I'm not
I'm I don't I'm uh oh it's just like
look and yes I would be delighted to uh
work on the show what about it it's just
like I guess I'm kind of like
I was in high school and had hookups in
high school like you don't get
completely naked and start having sex in
other people's homes what city does this
take place into it does anybody know for
half Virginia half Washington DC oh for
me uh Euphoria yeah Chatsworth I don't
know yes
great I don't think the city matter I
just think that when you're like a
teenager and you're hooking up you're
not like throwing off your like Asian
provocateur like bro I mean you like
kind of keep your shirt on I think it's
honestly was that the only person having
weird sex in closets and dry humping no
I think they're all doing that I wasn't
like doing reverse cowgirl on like the
you know football on the substitute yeah
you're like and why does no one have
braces oh in Euphoria yeah that is funny
teenagers like dude I had fucking
headgear like 12. dude I would head here
too dude I have a theory dude what's
your theory have you seen headgear in
the last 10 years on any kid
um if we were involved in some
orthodontist sex game dude no way well
you thought that was some BDSM shit
you're saying why do we have half of a
basketball hoop around our head it's
just why like I'm like dude why but
there was always one kid who would like
like I only wore it at night but there's
one kid who would like wear it to school
and I'm like you your parents need to uh
I don't know see Child Protective
Services you're totally it's just like
you make one false move you have like
tetanus you're just like so emerging
from the face yeah I mean it was just a
gar so you couldn't eat pussy
wherever you're going all goes oh I
would but
dudes are gonna bring back the fucking
DJ khaled's Gonna wear one of those ah
baby I will but I can't eat your pussy
you know but it's also like I do uh uh I
do think about that because I'm like
think about like there were so many odd
weird like creepy Orthodontics I feel
like there was a fish tank in the room
yeah remember when doctors had fish
tanks in the room
for what reason that's what I'm like
this isn't I'm not on the same health
insurance plan yeah they're playing
Jerry Springer in the lobby always and I
remember like like being like I remember
like they would take pictures of you
like when you were putting a brace is
this oh right I just like why are you
taking a Polaroid of me and this
headgear and why are you putting in your
back pocket why did you spray perfume on
it yeah I went to the dentist recently
there's so many little things you have
to do for an x-ray like how is it not
just one mold that goes dunk and then
just flashes it all at once also the
wildest shit about x-rays is like first
one you're not there's they cause cancer
like you have to go get X-ray like so
they'll um I went to get a mammogram it
happened uh that's on the tits fake
boobs yeah and so it's like a whole
thing and when they do the X-ray on you
you know as soon as you get have you got
one for like a broken mammogram no have
you got them have you got one for like
your body or something x-rays an x-ray
yeah at some point yeah and when they
started the technician
yeah and then they put this big metal
thing on you which is already like maybe
we shouldn't be doing this if you have
to be covered in a big metal cake oh
yeah I like those capes they feel good
it feels like a weighted blanket we'll
take a thunder thunder coat yeah does
that let me just be am I depressed
autism
but it felt comforting yeah because
we're gonna take this off it's like are
you it pushes down your um it makes it
so your parasynthetic nervous system
calms down it's like reducing cortisol
yeah if you have oh that's the whole
thing about weighted blankets yeah
that's and if you like have something on
top of you someone on top of you which
is why I'm a bottom it's just to release
stress
um and she said or no the guy knows a
guy there was another one uh one a woman
later but the guy goes um so are you
planning on having kids at any point and
I was like
I'm not I'm not sure yeah you know and
he was like uh all right well let's just
let's just put the thing on you anyway
so if you were within I no if I wasn't
he'd be like man oh oh oh wow and then I
was like so this thing would make it so
I'm infertile if you didn't put that on
not bad I would like like someone like
Elan an IUD for years or just go to the
dentist once pay 99 get the X-ray like
in someone fucking perfect this x-ray
thing like I don't think it's done yet
no no no they stopped this is that's
where people left you guys just gave up
on improving this fucking thing like
seeing inside people's bodies but it's
also um uh like I was uh uh doing this
corporate event and there was a guy
there who um his name is Alexander Wang
he's like an AI guy that is working on
improving self-driving cars and I was
like do these need Improvement like why
are they out self-driving cars like why
why is it out if it's not perfect just
you know it can hit somebody collect a
check or something it's just like a wild
thing have you seen those cars that have
like 50 cameras on it yeah I saw that
the other day I thought that was for
Google Maps there's there's two there's
one that's like self-driving you'll see
in a big city sorry to pitch you stuff
what about you should be a driver of
that thing a driver of a self-driver no
what no the thing that has all the
cameras on it like the Google well
because there's also Google guys hold on
yeah I would just drive by like only
fans girl's house I'm like what's up
what's up what's up
have you ever seen the ones that are the
um it's like a backpack for Google Maps
and it's a guy yeah yeah yeah do you
know what I see a lot in uh Hollywood is
like those little it's like the
Postmates delivery cars but it's like
the little car I feel so bad he's always
so alone everybody's like look at this
fucking idiot he's got his little
headlights on he's going all slow he's
waiting on the crosswalk by himself I'm
like somebody help that man or woman or
Coke what are you oh no you're gonna be
somebody who like is fighting for robots
that have rights you're that guy yes
okay but do you not feel bad when you
see it you know here's the thing you see
like a caterpillar on the ground and
you're like on Instagram live save the
caterpillars you can mount the mouth
um but I just maybe I was hungover no I
was in my field and I saw it I was like
because every time like my instinct my
instinct always is to make fun of and
then like lately I'm like dude that's a
person that's a thing I saw this guy in
Edmonton he was on a like like a like a
bike wheel it's just a one wheel like a
unicycle but it's a motorized oh yeah
nerd alert right
and he had a fox racing helmet and he
had a bad childhood and he was not loved
my instinct was to be like look at this
fucking pussy and I was like dude that's
a that's somebody living life like
nobody leaves their house anymore like
it Dawns like you I think what's
happening is you're getting more
successful like you just gotta have like
as you just get a more adult you start
sort of seeing things differently and
it's such a fucking bummer and you're
like ah God damn it I have a heart right
like I kind of thought I was a
psychopath Cloud at 24 I would have gone
live on these girls look at this fucking
pussy on 5th and Washington I mean yeah
it's also like doing these roasts it's
like I started doing the roasts like 15
years ago when it was like you know Joan
Rivers it was I was like Joan River's a
soul she has a separate entrance for
black cocks you know I mean it was a
little fucking kid like Pam Anderson I
feel bad about this and I'm I'm gonna
keep apologizing because they're
documenting you have a contact what's
that you ever contact I could get it
probably on Reddit y'all have all the
shit dude I look on Reddit and I see
like celebrity addresses they're true
don't say that oh sorry
a lot of people can make Millennium it's
on there and like it like you know you
the people you can hardly and people can
hardly get to my house as it is
um but uh Pam Anderson it was the roast
of
uh David Hasselhoff and I said I'm uh
Pam Anderson has dated Tommy Lee Kid
Rock and Brett Michaels why don't you
just save yourself some time and drink a
vat of Magic Johnson's blood
I mean it's too mean and I look back and
I'm like oh my God how like how could I
have said that well I did need money but
all right well that'll do it as I get
older it's same thing you know that
thing the Roomba yeah when it gets stuck
under the couch I'm like buddy that's
what I'm saying hey buddy buddy okay
well it like says messages it's like
it's by the stairs and I'm like don't
jump don't jump around but I need to
that's true there's croutons no it'll
say like it'll be like it's like I
forget what the notification was I don't
have one but my friend showed me the
Roomba has an app yeah whoa everything
has an app God that is the Loneliest
shit I've heard in a while someone just
checking in on their Roomba well it'll
notifications like this stuck on a cord
or something but it but I forget what
the notification was my friend showed me
but it was like it was like it is stuck
needs help and I was like buddy buddy
but also we're coming at 2023 that's
what type of stuff we're talking in the
washing machine what are we doing step
Roomba it's so dumb but yeah so I don't
know if a lot of cities have this I
think maybe LA and New York I don't know
but they're a little they're called
Cocos I think and they're like a little
yeah they're cooler on wheels that
delivers I've never seen anybody get
food from one how about this if you're
like a Postmates or doordash driver in
La when you see them do you just fucking
kick up into the ocean just a quick
swear blind spot yeah it's just like
fuck you like why are you like taking
jobs from like La strippers dude but
also
um I had a rescue dog that um had had
what happened Coco hit it there was
another there's another one he uh uh was
this like black pitbull and you know uh
it was like very very sweet and you know
never attacked other dogs but had had
some you know like really bad um was in
dog fighting where you said like really
bad injuries and stuff and I like worked
so hard for him to be able to like be
socialized and he was walking with my
dog walker in Santa Monica and uh uh
Sheila calls me and she's like um we
have to take uh Magic to the vet and I
was like what happened she was like he
attacked a Coco um so dogs are attacking
these things like this video of him like
attacking them like a cocoa like just
biting the fuck out of yeah of course
and it was like so hard to I was just
like oh my God this poor little robot
yeah I think is gonna really be a
problem in the future of oh a dog's
attacking those things I don't know just
robots in general like the fact that we
anthropomorphize them you know I have a
robot from my fourth special and um I
did all the like you know research on
that and yeah and I was in the robot uh
guys that owned sex doll and sex robot
chat rooms for about a year I was like
in there like you have their contact uh
I probably do it's on Reddit asking for
me and then um uh and watching them and
the way that they had these emotional
attachments to these dolls and robots
over time they would literally be asking
questions like hey I don't know what to
do it's like I don't want to leave her
home alone so I just leave the TV on for
her what the fuck
dude it's kind of wild house leave the
TV on she is a TV she's fucking
cooperating with the satellite here's
when it's gonna get lonely is when La
comedians are buying these and they're
not only fucking them they're using them
for validation it's gonna you're gonna
come home it's gonna make good set honey
you're so funny you are number one
comedian in Los Angeles and you're like
yeah babe now blow me won't make a
grilled cheese and she goes I already
made you once and you're like what else
do I need Ryan no I have a robot I'm
putting um chat GPT in her
why would you do that like just so she
can have better conversations she can
talk yeah of course
yeah yes uh you don't know you don't
know about my robot talking here no I
I saw a video recently the fucking I did
take my sex drive out on Joe Rogan but
she didn't really talk much on it
so stupid and then afterwards
um oh see here she is on like like some
show
was she talking or not no oh fucking
bitch oh there she is no she's talking
here a woman not talking
when's that true
this is her talking
so we're still working on her
because every time I answer my Tom Brady
she talks too much about it okay like
it's basically
junior is an American football
quarterback for the news I love her
that's my wife right there there she is
come home good set honey you are funnier
than every comedian
she sounds like who is the guy hanging
out of the wheelchair that was really
smart
Stephen Hawking yeah really quick what
are you looking for in a gal
just want somebody who I can support and
they can support me and get a text for
once in a while no no no get a text have
a great show tonight have fun they
understand the work life and oh you're
gonna be gone for nine days but when you
get back I'll be there arms open why can
they come with you
here's the thing I want that but I want
that but also I've slept with my first
fan
only fan
um but I want that but also in the you
gotta like know how somebody operates
because like if you take somebody on the
road and I'm like quiet like an hour
before going on she's like are you mad
at me I'm like no I'm just going over
bitch that's a red flag like I just it's
like I need to like I wanted to
integrate slowly hey see me at the laugh
Factor okay we saw that oh you see me do
a headline La show boom now it's like
when you're on the road like the road
life you're literally a princess on the
road like you the way like you get
treated it's like it's it's hard to
you're like everything you know on the
road from the second you wake up to the
show Princesses don't get treated great
Kate Middleton and Megan they get a lot
of shit yeah but the billionaires yeah
who gives a shit they're doing better
than a guy you know what else by the way
if a girl tells you you're are you mad
at me it's that drives me nuts are you
mad at me no you're mad at your dad call
him but figure out what happens you know
everything I do before a show I'm doing
to like somehow make myself better make
the set better working out going over
this this and that it's like I don't
wanna well they need to be at the Ross
for Less
where girls can meet up with other girls
look the lady's out there and I just
want because like I think the touring
life is really hard for other people to
understand and it's really draining for
us and we're not here to entertain you
right but but but the part of my nature
because I'm a good man with loving
parents just I'll be like are you good
do you need anything are you is it no
I'm out of the right yeah so you're not
away at a point I do that too when I
have people on the road with me I become
a waitress I'm like do you need anything
wow you okay another water and I'm like
yeah exactly So eventually eventually
something like that and maybe with a fat
ass you know something like that you can
look for is it too much to ask for get
me on Ryan no why is that what you mean
leave you're not on right yeah but
here's the thing I'm outraged now you
know I'm gonna boycott there we go well
I've been on it I don't know how to get
off I was on it like five years that's
the thing every time I tell somebody I
don't have it they're like you I don't
even use this fucking thing my dogs are
on it can you take my account or
something what if we just put your photo
up
on mine and then you can log into mine
like you can have mine the message is
like can you do that can you take
someone's Riot account
maybe we could change the preferences I
don't know what you're into but we could
change it I
it's waiting in too I mean look I think
I know my
syndication no you just take a vision
board and you throw it at a wall and you
go
those those four pieces my vision board
is a fucking hot mess Ellen was on it
hey y'all you know you know when like
guys now they'll be like you look like a
snack
um the only time I'll take that as a
compliment is if a guy's like you look
like a factor meal
Factor meals I discovered it because it
was sent to me by uh the smartest person
in my life uh when my mom died recently
and now I'm obsessed so if you are too
busy to cook this spring with factors
skip the trip to the grocery store
grocery store and skip the chopping the
prepping the cleaning up the crying the
the avocado hand you know about avocado
hand people will cut avocados in their
hand and stab it right through don't
Google that it will really mess up your
algorithm factors fresh never frozen
meals are ready in just two minutes all
you have to do is heat and enjoy and
then get back outside and soak up the
warmer weather with 34 plus Chef
prepared dietitian approved weekly
options there's always something new to
try with Factor you can rest assured
that you're making a sustainable choice
we offset 100 renewable electricity for
our production sites that is awesome and
offices and features sustainably sourced
Seafood in our meals head to
factormeals.com whitney50 and use code
Whitney 50 to get 50 off your first box
that's code whitney50 at factormeals.com
whitney50 to get 50 off your first box
like how people are gonna find this Rose
outside of the bubble of like the birds
and the Toms in that world is going to
be from the clips it's like a clip going
viral on Tick Tock which is like a 30
second clip totally so it's taking that
and then dishing it out there yeah and
it's like word of mouth too you know
it's like I think they're like Word of
Mouth Whitney what year are you living
in the back of the commentary you guys
seeing this is you not read all about it
we are back to Word of Mouth like what
does it take to get you to watch a movie
I have to have some my the first I
respect the most to say like I just saw
this movie you got to see it yeah but my
friends are dumb here's the thing if I
see clips about people posting about it
on Tick Tock that's when I'll do it if I
see like multiple posts I'm like oh this
must be a thing I think I just mean like
with like because I was trying to figure
out if we were gonna do a billboard
campaign with this what's a marketing
can I see my face on Sunset Boulevard
yeah
party bus tomorrow night really and
we're gonna go to a crazy girl's strip
club after really oh so I should all
plans after just cancel them just Why
did why I don't see what plans
no I don't have any plans but we're
going uh afterwards to crazy girl strip
club
I don't know lotion cocoa butter
foreign
[Music]
I'm so sick of seeing comedians in
sweatshirts and hoodies it's just like
it's enough already guys the pandemic's
over sleepover's over what about a crew
neck
zipper a butt like oh
yeah no I I like it I'm gonna probably
uh have to I'm gonna be running around
so much I'm just gonna be like jeans or
whatever but it's like it's just like
not yeah not under armor that's all I
ask okay just is that not roots not a
Roots hoodie yeah is that so much
specific yeah yeah I think I think of a
certain person in line right now yeah
I'm just saying yeah no no I got you
I'll wear a little zip up from a co-op
like nothing from like a lot of press
gonna be there tomorrow yeah there's
gonna be a lot of press Just Jared is
gonna be there that's a big deal just oh
they're like just Jared's coming to
cover it I'm like that's well it's like
this is the biggest like tablet now
Oh I thought wait isn't Jared a wedding
ring
yes Jeremy cave yeah Jewelers okay
Jeweler every kiss begins with k yeah I
K Jewelers or team always cracks me up
because it's the idea of like if you
give a woman a ring from K and propose
she's she's it's like will you marry me
she's like okay oh
yeah uh that's great is there gonna be
popular I'm so obsessed with pitching
sketches for you I like this idea of
like
like if you get a ring from Jared oh you
know that there's a hotline like a guy
once got me an engagement ring and you
there's a hotline where you call it a
return and you have to explain what
happened can you imagine being the
person taking those calls
like I would want face time I beg let me
see the guy what does he look like I'll
tell you what happened yeah let me see
the bank account yeah you're right that
does not match up I just it's so funny
the jewelry store is just like some guy
like David's Bridal like chairs people
don't work there David's Bridal is a
real I know I know I see him on the road
all the time
fucking dresses from David's Bridal it's
all like a white like like uh long white
with a long white Veil should be called
David Duke's Bridal let's go there it is
damn we're getting we're getting fired
up today I know I mean like is Paparazzi
gonna be the spot I've never had
Paparazzi every time I landed LAX I have
like this like split moment where I look
up and I'm like are they here no never
yeah that's my spirit though you have to
fly Delta calls it's Delta usually I
feel like wait really yeah usually it's
still tough I feel like everything Delta
there's like people just like post up
outside because it's like how else are
you gonna make money if you work at the
freaking Delta counter you can call and
say oh Trevor Wallace is gonna be on
this flight and they wait outside wow I
thought people just call Paparazzi on
themselves a lot do very sad I tried and
the Olympian Saddle Ranch tonight look
cool good night yeah or they just go to
Crags or whatever but like yeah but it's
like there's um you know what I don't
hate that I mean good for you I don't
think I do it well it's it but when I
found out my friend did it is when she
went through a breakup the dude cheated
and she's like Fuck you and then she
goes on a hot date with a hot dude and
goes I'm gonna be here snap some photos
store it online and then that dude
seeing it like what I wonder what the
other guy cheated on her and left her
she seems like such a I mean like if I
show you who this person was you'd be
like get it yeah for sure I mean it's
just like an la love couple there's no
love they're just they're just like you
know it's all just emotions and just
egos
this is how people fucking Los Angeles
yeah like somebody who's never clapped
before this movie is so good
um I love you where are you going now
I'll be in New York next week ooh when
I'm gonna be there on the third for
Schultz uh I'll be there through the
seventh when do you third through
seventh what hotel are you staying at
what address
uh Motel Six please sugar mamas hit me
up what are you gonna be doing I'm gonna
go hit bar stool no probably I mean I'm
doing a bunch of college gigs in PA in
New York and I'm like let me just have a
life for a second and go to the city for
a few days doing a show at a Chelsea
music hall and then uh just I just wanna
um let you know we're in no rush you can
like say Pennsylvania like are you in a
rush I don't know how to spell it you
have somewhere to be yeah do I have
someone to be no I'm doing Woody's
podcast this shit's gonna go for seven
hours I blocked off no it's not dinner
no we gotta be out here by like one what
is wrong with me what you know what it
is because you love me don't you I am I
love the time spending today I am
obsessed with you there was a i I'm
totally obsessed get it live you know
I'm obsessed I remember one time someone
sent me a clip of you I think it was
your Char Ali journalist of you did you
ever do stand up like during the
pandemic on like a boat I did yeah like
where was that uh Lake Havasu
oh yeah anything happens on a boat in
Lake Havasu this is wild okay so he sent
me a video he's like this guy is super
funny do you know this guy and I was
just like well he's on a boat so I
probably like I there's no way I like
this guy he's amazing I already hate
this guy he's on a boat like he's doing
stand up on a boat like what is this
like maritime law a bunch of Finance
Bros coked out I can do some stand up
you want to hear type five I'm like this
says big crew Pomade energy and I did
blow dry my hair before this unlike some
people
Zinger
Zinger and you do have an incredible
hairline thank you thank you so much do
you think it makes people like do you
think that men having a great hairline
is like women having like amazing tits
do you think it makes guys like jealous
of you I definitely think so oh wow I
didn't even think about it yeah I think
it does I'm sure wow all the guys I know
that have incredible hairlines they're
like guys they're not they're like fuck
that guy and you don't know why and
you're like I think that guy's cool and
you're like oh yeah damn I never thought
about that I think did you see what
Drake's therapist said to him he's
online no it was all over online I'm not
close with Drake the only reason I'm
first name base is with him is that's
what he goes by online
or sorry Aubry Aubrey Graham he's a
rapper Canadian but his therapist goes
like he's like I've lost attention on me
every time I walk in the room and his
therapist in the weirdest way possible
his therapist goes you have the biggest
tits in the room when you walk in that's
like what it's like and I was like your
therapist works at Barstool Sports what
therapist is like yo you gotta fuck
you got some jugs and if people are
looking because you got triple d's and
embrace it let me know if you want to
drive together tomorrow I'm going at
like five five yeah that's true I mean
it starts at 6 30.
yeah all right I'll give those 6 30.
isn't this what people enjoy about
podcasts listening to two people make
plans for the next day that they're not
invited to I'm like do you want to drive
together yeah like I genuinely am like
this where there's not like 50 000
people right now I'd be like I want to
drive meet me in the car I love you uh
yeah but you have a house that's so nice
I feel like I could take something and
you wouldn't know I would notice right
away really there's something about like
having friends who are just like you
know you know I feel like I could just
be like it's a nice camera let's see
thanks for the cat you know okay so
Molly Kimmel is married to Jimmy Kimmel
her sister is one of my favorite people
on the planet I really want to say that
I came up with this idea but every time
we're like Christmas like the rounds of
Christmas parties in December what she
and her husband do is every party they
go to they'll take like one of the
ornaments off the tree and the next year
they'll give it to that person as a gift
and see if they notice it's such a like
dumb like we'll just be at like
someone's house I'm like what ornament
should we take and we spend all this
time trying to figure it out and then
the next time they were gonna steal it
and then put it at the other Christmas
party no it's you give it to the person
whose tree it was on the year before and
then you watch them open it and see if
they notice well an ornament as a gift
anyways you're like what the fuck is a
shitty like it's so funny and then you
gotta hold on to it for a year yeah
because it's also like like they open it
and they're like oh my God thank you so
much and we're like you're such an
asshole my last name yeah
well she doesn't even know her ornaments
but it's like what kind of asshole
steals ornaments and plots this for the
entire year like that's my kind of bitch
I would do it it sounds fun I love you
I'm excited to see you tomorrow thank
you for having me I'm excited to see the
reactions and um after my set plays I'm
gonna say stop pause I'm gonna go there
was more funny jokes
everyone's got cut everyone no I know
just as an ego thing I'm just gonna be
like guys there was there's some really
good stuff DM me and I will DM them to
you personally no but I just think if
you like putting it on yourself you're
gonna get more out of a point on your
social you know and I also really wanted
to make sure I was providing content for
people for their socials so that I'm not
the only person like of course but also
there's Parts in that in in my like 15
minutes where I agreed that it felt too
scripted it felt so I'm this the stuff
you put in there it felt fun it felt
loose it felt like not like like very
stiff so it feels good it's a good flow
too I think I think the editing on it is
great I mean I spent I truly went
through 10 iterations where it was like
I was trying again I've been working on
this since the second you hit cut on
whatever night that was like you until
now had this like magical moment and
like so few people can like go back and
forth with someone like Donnell like
that except rainiestly and I just wanted
to like you know I was nervous
I was nervous I bet but it didn't show
Whitney I love you thanks for having me
[Music]
[Applause]